[Musik]
so sind sie nicht kennt oder slave der
schweizer brachte zeit wenig wurde und
hier nach haben
am anfang bin ich aktiv afrika habe raum
erklärten die probleme unter anderem
stammbuch ihr könnt und am schluss bin
ich deiner zog wo das risiko lauert da
sie das rolltor hin was ist der lohn für
jemanden der sein leben zu einem
abenteuer macht und was sind die
gefahren
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
die geschichte dieses kühnen lebens
begann vor 20 jahren damals wanderte der
schweizer nach kenia haus seine erste
herausforderung fahnder in einem
verwilderten nationalpark der von
banditen beherrscht wurde
in dieser wilden gegend baute er an den
wunsch für touristen
finanziert wurde der aufbau durch einen
deutschen partner
sicherheit ist so betrieb ist so co es
ist wieder leben
die power co wir haben sich an die
bundes der vertriebenen im nationalpark
banditen und der unsicherheit sind die
vor ort wo verlosen troll ihren risch
oder wohnungen drehtages auto für die
fahrt sohnes auto ist einfach zum
überfluss unterlief aber in norwegen
bietet reichlich betrieb ist wie und wo
wo bewegung ist gott also jemand durch
das ganze land um zufrieden zu ihren
automatisch es ist nicht so dass man
muss die musiker jeden nach dem bau der
lodge sowie sind weiter heute lebt ein
kategorie a in westport kannte also das
einzige moni eigene bewussten schweiz
mit noah ist der vampir hat meine frau
gemacht afrika relevante deutschland bis
mir viel bedeutet und das mit mehr sieht
inhaltlich über eine mikro bis jetzt
dorfkapelle punkten und drei liegen ja
gleich mit runde
ich bin ja nicht der nacht zum schwitzen
transportieren wieder eine hohe summe
wachstum im labor seine alte heimat ist
der aargau dort wuchsen auf heiratete
gründete eine familie und arbeitete als
bezirksschule lehrer und rektor
karotten zwei hinter und dann ist es
plötzlich mit dem rolf gruber gar um so
sind sie es brauchen
ja ihr habt frau verlor sie hätte die
eigene hobbys und bekanntschaften und so
rund und so intensiv wurde ja wo mir nix
ist im video jährlich zwei oder drei mal
nach kenia gereist
und während das geständnis ksk ist
afrika
aber irgendein ist wie einfach wirklich
die familie hat ihm längst verziehen
reisende soll man bekanntlich nicht
aufhalten
oft genug werden sie sowieso gestoppt
doch unerwartete ereignisse so auch
jetzt
das linke vorderrad
sie machen sich jetzt mit den anderen
angenommen
wie aus dem nichts taucht hilfe auf drei
junge ziegenherden ja das habe bisher
eine positive doch gelegen so etwas
passiert sofort lütjenburger sofort
verkaufen
weil sie jetzt im rat der flügellahmen
habe das gleich noch das gleich noch
ja ja mit nur vier monaten pro rad geht
es weiter etwas rechts und zwar aber
ohne erneute panne die trockene wüste
ist über 200 kilometer lang
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieses mädchen berührt sein herz sehr
die zweijährige vielleicht tochter
seiner freundin das ist sie wenig
sie wohnt noch bei den eltern sowohl
vater als auch mutter wissen angeblich
nichts über die intime beziehung
zwischen ihrer tochter und dem schweizer
sie ist 26 66
die 40 jahre altersunterschied stören
das ungleiche paar keineswegs beide
profitieren voneinander
golf ist ein guter mensch weil er
großzügig ist wenn jemand zu ihm kommt
und ihn bittet das schulgeld für die
kinder zu bezahlen
so macht er das selbst dann wenn er die
leute nicht kennt er hilft vielen und
sorgt für meine tochter und für uns alle
dass sie in jeßnitz wie sie im westen
sind spitze ließ sich also das im detail
aber mit dem meer muss unten klappen in
afrika so lange wie sind und anders
sehen
die spitze lius nützel gebieten
aber so lange sich das im rahmen der
störte sie stört es nicht die hand die
höhere junge frau die hatte für junge
frauen bin ich ja ja ja so bezirke die
ziege kann man doch nicht es aber nicht
so definiere die sind offen für waffen
aus bier ist
ich weiß wirklich nicht warum honig
mitte wenig ja nicht ganz sicher ob sie
gegen 9 uhr finden sie entnehmen das
telefon und das könnte zu groß werden
dass sie jetzt nicht was sie tragen das
jetzt als lager nicht
[Musik]
unterwegs ist er meist allein denn nicht
selten führen seine reisen durch
gefährliche regionen
nach dem bau der touristen los so wer im
nordwesten kenias einen handel mit honig
auf dabei riskierte er kopf und kragen
ja das stereo und vorantreiben überfall
wurde ist russischer sommer sich
schlechter und wie fährt langsam wieder
als fahrer in der kurve sind plötzlich
drei liegt vor mir gestanden
mit kalaschnikows offen
eine sofort den kopf gesetzt und die
andere ist reine gestanden und eine
steuer gestanden so schnell gegangen ihr
behaltet können reagieren
da hat sich auto und zum glück von jedem
spieler kann eine gmbh
auch das telefon im auto liegen skelette
stelle von hannes g und den zins sind
gut generell sind zwar auch nervös klima
schien nach seiner für mehr öko
ich bin ich gegangen ist ein riesenstein
vom herzen gefallen
die lage ist angespannt im gebiet wo der
überfall stattfand
kinder und frauen haben sich in die
büsche zurückgezogen
nutztiere sind ihren reichtum und das
kapital deswegen liefern sich die beiden
stämme popkultur karner einen blutigen
krieg aber das ist nicht der einzige
grund für die unsichere situation es
geht s w
konflikte sind kittel röslers also dir
wohnen für stahl und gummi dass ich sehr
gut also degott strom größe die man
gewachsene und raunen umstände und wenn
ihr privat weder für chance auf hilfe
der wind für hüte die andere die andere
varianten ist sind die straßen befahren
war einfach zu recht als eine touristen
fahrzeuge bevor war hatte um geld und
tilgungen bezogen und wenn wir bis geht
der autor der telefon hat der basierte
gut wenn minute traf sie dass sie an
abschlüssen in diesen vergessenen
konfliktgebiet haben schon unzählige
menschen ihr leben verloren
das beschäftigt den schweizer der hat
seit jahren mit beiden verfeindeten
stämmen zu tun
früher kaufte er sowohl dem code als
auch den pokal honig ab dann schulde er
die einheimischen im anbau von salave
aus sisal fasern lassen sich teppiche
und schnüre herstellen bevor funke hat
ihn uns gegangen und habe einen fehler
mache ich hoffe die haben verschiedene
gebiete geschafft johannes projektchor
in der region war dem projekt sei das
unfriede geht das spanier geht sauber
direct berlin ihr in einen unfall
verwickelt sie aber häufig ist oder wenn
man antworten
doch eine theorie die kriegen sie jetzt
und ist natürlich für das projekt sauber
- amt mitgliedschaft für mich gar nicht
vorwärts nur mehr an die zukunft und da
hat mir einfach ist ja automatisch
es war schon mal lässig wenn man aber
auch geschäftsführer fried du 2009
begann ruft nur mit dem bau einer
neutralen begegnungsstätte ernannte sie
karabach das zentrum befindet sich genau
auf der grenzlinie der verfeindeten
stämme menschen beider städte haben hier
die möglichkeit sich zu treffen und
kennenzulernen
finanziert wird das begegnungszentrum
der krienser frau die er das schweizer
hilfswerk fördert den konfliktregionen
projekte der esskultur
regelmäßig finden anlass der stadt an
denen essen und trinken gerade die so
verehrt wird
die so geschaffene atmosphäre
erleichtert die gespräche am
verhandlungstisch
tatsächlich kamen schon mehrmals die
stammesführer beider völker ins
restaurant grabosch um friedensgespräche
zu führen
seit november 2015 wird nicht mehr
gekämpft
verstärkte militärpräsenz in der region
und die begegnungsstätte sind die gründe
dafür
[Musik]
gefängnis statt gewehrschüsse erfüllen
heute die luft die menschen sind
entspannt sie freuen sich auf ein
bevorstehendes friedensfest fast an das
rechte und karstadt zum
friedensförderung beatrice ich glaub es
wichtig ist wo mehr betreiber zu hand
ist kompetenz ist echt und prediger
non-stop politiker jetzt muss einfach
weitergehen
wer nicht auf gewissen vorsprung aber
ins kriege tim sommer sind wir dort
blieb und angesagt wenn wir jetzt
springe denn ich das auch wieder schwach
zeichen meint also wird story kauter
jeder situation ist nun mal einig was
muss muss was ganz großes zimmer sind
bin ich einfach und auch ludwig no mit
dem polizeichef mohammed liebe danke an
der zeremonie nehmen angehörige aus
beiden stämmen teil
schon beim tanzen frauen aus dem volk
der turkana während sich die andere
volksgruppe faurés zurückhält und dann
ereignet sich ein historischer moment
und dort tanzen gemeinsam
[Musik]
das pace zieht sich weit in die nacht
hinein
[Musik]
es scheint dass ein neues zeitalter
begonnen hat zwischen den beiden völkern
völliger neubau auf lernte viel
mächtiger aber die opernbühne sehr
braucht dann zu bitten und und ich sehe
wo sie wirken in den haag unterwegs sein
und zwar vor ferner und ist wahnsinnig
so unglaublich es ist würde symbol
sowohl das dritte welt bedeutet über und
hinter der bühne beobachten polizisten
und soldaten den anlass sie werden auch
in zukunft dafür sorgen dass der frieden
eingehalten wird
für ihn ist das friedensfest
gleichzeitig ein höhepunkt wie auch ein
abschied von karabach ab jetzt
übernehmen einheimische die
begegnungsstätte rolf chlor wird aber
weiterhin als berater zur verfügung
stehen
ein schweizer trägt maßgeblich dazu bei
dass zweifel kann miteinander frieden
schließen
die welt nimmt davon kenntnis aber hier
nordkenia wird der aargauer fast als
heiliger verehrt wir glauben dass rolf
von gott gesandt wurde
er ist ein prophet denn mit ihm kam der
frieden
ich glaube rolf ist wie moses in der
bibel
er befreite uns und brachte uns mit den
nachbar stimmen zusammen
befriedigend
[Musik]
der abenteurer reicht es schon oft ans
ende der welt sein aktuelles projekt
liegt allerdings noch ein paar schritte
weiter
[Musik]
wir befinden uns im grenzgebiet zwischen
äthiopien und kenia um fast 300 km
langen und 60 km breiten turkana see
gibt es nur gerade ein hotel
es gehört dem schweizer schon einmal
stand hier ein gasthaus es rentierte
sich nicht und zerfiel
dann kam auf chlor und nun wird laufend
renoviert und ausgebaut
außer fisch gibt es keine nahrungsmittel
aus der region
alles andere muss über weite distanzen
durch die wüste hergebracht werden
bereits hat er 18 menschen aus der
umgebung angestellt er selber verdiene
aber noch nichts am unternehmen
dennoch fehlen im zahlreiche gäste ich
hoffe so im regen eine schleusten elia
und torun bin ja im raum
bodenverbesserer die ganze zweite jahr
ist das besagt das hotel weckt auch
hoffnungen der bevölkerung der herrn
umgebung
die monatliche landschaft durch die
keine straße führt zählt zu den ärmsten
regionen ostafrikas nun hofft der
einwohnerrat dieses dorfes auf die hilfe
des weißen die einheimischen möchten ihr
kunsthandwerk an touristen verkaufen er
könne durch seine hotelgäste zu ihnen
schicken sagen sie heftig gewartet dass
mir möglich wo der nachhaltigen und
und so hat ruft nur wieder eine neue
aufgabe zu lösen
herausforderungen prägen seinen
abenteuerlichen weg ein weg mitgefahren
aber auf freiheit der freiheit aus jeder
routine auszubrechen
[Musik]